[موسيقى]
كلمات وجمل تراها في الشوارع وعلى التوك
توك والسيارات وحتى في رسائل الهاتف كم
والاخطاء اللغويه والنحويه عكست التدهور
الذي اصاب اللغه العربيه المصريون يرون ان
الافراط في العاميه يعد من اهم الاسباب
لهذا التظاهري خصوصا لدى الاجيال الجديده
[موسيقى]
فكله بيتكلم كده باللغه العاميه مشكله
باللغه العربيه الاولى وتكات تكون المشكله
الاساسيه في كل حاجه ان اللغه العربيه همم
اندثرت والعاميه طغرت على كل شيء في
الميديا والاعلام مسموع مقروء حتى
المكتبات التي تعد ملازا للمتذوقين
لجماليات اللغه العربيه الفصحى بدات تسخر
بكتب العاميه الكتاب الجداد لما بيكتبوا
بالعاميه بيوصلوا الشباب لان الشباب للاسف
ما تعلموش اللغه العربيه زي زمان حاولنا
الراس ده اسباب هذا التدهور امام المدارس
التجريبيه والحكوميه ياكد الطلاب واولياء
امورهم ان سوق العمل المستقبلي يفرض اجاده
للغات الاجنبيه كاولويه للتعيين ما فيش
صعوبه في العربي ولا الانجليزي بس انا ما
تبين شغلانه في مصر تعتمد على انجلش يعني
اكثر من اي لغه ثانيه كمان اختيار بالعربي
بلغه اساسا يعني
[موسيقى]
وفي احدى المدارس الخاصه يبدو المشهد
مختلفا اهتمام بتعلم العربي باساليب شيقه
وممتعه والهدف هو جعلها ماده محببه وليست
مجرد ماده للنجاح فحسب احنا دائما في
تدرسنا اللغه العربيه بنتجه للطرق اللي هي
بتحب الاولاد في اللغه العربيه زي مثلا
اغاني بسيطه مثلا لعب هزار الحاجات دي هي
بتبقى قريبه جدا من سن الصغير وهي بتحببهم
في التدريب في اللغه العربيه بشكل عام
يعني يعني
اخرون يحاولون تغيير هذا النمط التقليدي
في تعلم العربيه واستبداله باساليب جاذبه
الطلاب انهاج نفسه يسعى لبعض لتطبيقه مع
الاطفال ويظل
رهانه على امكانيه ظهور الجيل الجديد
المحب وعاشقا للغته العربيه في عالم فيه
اللغات الاجنبيه
رهان ليس سهلا فاللغه لم تعد لسا كما كانت
في السابق لكنها تحولت الى اداه مهمه في
سوق العمل وهو ما سيحدد مصير لغه الضاد في
المستقبل احمد عثمان العربيه